ps2
[Musique]
si on ne connaît pas encore la date
prévue du déconfinement le gouvernement
a été clair à deux mois du début des
vacances d'été inutile de se faire trop
d'illusions sur les possibles
destinations de voyage il ya une semaine
le secrétaire d'état aux transports jean
baptiste djebbari annoncé je conseille
aux français la plus grande prudence sur
la préparation de leur voyage car la
situation aujourd'hui est encore trop
incertaines
je leur dis d'attendre mais alors
comment s'organiser pour cet été dans ce
climat d'incertitude
pour didier arino président directeur du
cabinet protourisme spécialiste des
études et du conseil dans le secteur du
tourisme
la situation est tendue il ya
relativement peu d'annulations mais on a
encore moins de réservations très
concrètement certains n'osent pas
annulée car ils vont perdre leur raconte
d'autres sont optimistes et se disent
qu'ils vont pouvoir partir avec la
fermeture des frontières de nombreux
français qui avaient l'intention de
partir à l'étranger révisent leurs plans
et organise des vacances dans l'hexagone
mais alors comment s'organiser pour
l'été voilà merci d'être avec nous
commençons crise et pour les problèmes
de lumière sa lumière et tu m'as dit
pendant le sujet mais toi néons dans le
cul sacrifier vos vacances d'été
ben alors on a géré mars la bac est avec
nous alors ils vont fermer a priori les
frontières on pourra pas aller à
l'étranger
bernard qu'est ce qui va se passer pour
cet été il ya plein de français qui nous
regardent et plein de gens me disent
qu'est ce qu'on va faire c'est est ce
que les français vont pouvoir aller en
vacances
ouhlala bah là pour parler comme si je
vous dis que c'est lula
non je pense qu'on va pas aller jusque
là on va attendre le 11 mai pour savoir
exactement s'il y aura ceux des
confinement ou pas je pense que c'est
très important
est-ce qu'ils vont mettre en place des
visas sanitaire c'est ce que je souhaite
qu'on puisse voyager est ce qu'on va
être tracée pour nous permettre de
savoir exactement jusqu'où pourra aller
je pense que les frontières en dehors de
l'europe seront définitivement fermés
jusqu'au mois de septembre c'est à dire
qu'on pourra pas faire de longs
courriers cyril il faut le dire aux
téléspectateurs
mais pour l'instant n'a nul et pas vos
vacances vous n'allez pas partir en
france dé pouvoir partir en corse vous
allez pouvoir tire un petit peu dans les
différentes destinations
peut-être même en grèce j'te dans tous
les cas le confinement lé déconfinement
commence à bien fonctionner en grèce si
on fait beaucoup plus tôt c'est
complètement arrêté
j'ai des nouvelles en toile antoine
griezmann me dit
ce que j antoine voilà qui vient de
m'envoyer un sms antoine griezmann que
j'embrasse fort qui me dit voilà il lui
les confiner en espagne et c'est vrai
voilà pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
déconfinement mais ça ça avance et un
petit peu ils sont un petit peu dans le
même timing que nous en espagne j'ai
fait un gros bisou antoine que j'aime
très très fort oui bernard on est on est
à trois mois un de ces vacances
scolaires donc attendons un tout petit
peu je pense qu'il n'est pas bondée nul
et si vous avez déjà réservé par contre
si vous ne souhaitez pas pour l'instant
vous n'avez pas encore réservé attendait
ce 11 mai pour voir si je considère être
plus long voilà dimanche bernard est ce
que les français qui ont réservé leurs
vacances vous êtes remboursé
ouh là là alors ils ne m'ont pas être
remboursés il ya une ordonnance du 25
mars du premier ministre edouard
philippe qu'a dit la chose suivante
toutes les personnes qui ont versé un
acompte ou un voyage dans sa globalité
entre le 1er mars et le 15 sept ans tous
ces voyages vote à transformer en avoir
syrie on a voit alors justement non 18
ans ça sera valable 18 mois alors
justement beaucoup d'agents de voyages
proposent d'autres offres pour pallier à
l'annulation est ce qu'on a le droit de
les refuser
ouh là là et refuse avait soudain des
réseaux aussi vous avez droit des
refuges
je vous rappelle quand même les agences
de voyages ça veut dire qu'on a le droit
de refuser donc ce voyage là on a le
droit de refuser plusieurs fois et après
les 18 mois vous pourrez être remboursés
totalement alors est ce que bernard
bernard sabbah concernant les billets
d'avion est ce que les français vont
être remboursés ouh là là là
alors là c'est là c'est le vrai souci
est le vrai problème voir vos
chroniqueurs lève le doigt ils veulent
parler mais je pense que c'est important
que je leur dise quelque chose de
l'essentiel aujourd'hui c'est le combat
qu'il faut mener site auprès des
compagnies aériennes
il ya deux cent quatre-vingt dix
compagnies aériennes dans le monde qui
prennent tout le monde en otage
les tours opérators les agences de
voyages les sillons à chaud quand on a
acheté un vol sec
on ne peut pas être remboursés alors que
logiquement ça devrait l'être ça c'est
pas normal c'est inadmissible et je
comprends que des marques comme mr fly
comme ookoodoo comme beau voyage se bat
aujourd'hui pour aider et même les
agences de voyages se bat pour aider et
si à rembourser les clients ils ne
peuvent pas ils n'ont pas l'argent
personne ne venant rendre cet argent ça
c'est inadmissible ça c'est un vrai
combat d'accord donc ça c'est ça c'est
moi ça c'est un vrai vrai vrai problème
juste
là est ce que les hôtels a priori est ce
que les hôtels en france et voilà les
clubs de vacances les campings vont
réouvrir
oui je l'espère je pense qu'ils vont pas
ouvrir le 15 mai ça c'est pas possible
ça me paraît difficile
je pense qu objectivement les campings
va rouvrir au mois de juin et de juillet
jeu mais j'espère qu'on aura géré ce
fameux confinement déconfinement parce
que comme perdue higoumène tout à
l'heure nous mettre en place des offres
spéciales les campi les clubs de
vacances ou tout ça oulala mais oui oui
une série c'est obligatoire
vous avez des gens comme céline qui ont
pu relancer les dés des offres de haut
niveau du camping très intéressant je ne
dis pas qu'elles seront intéressantes le
15 août évidemment parce que toulouse va
se ruer vers cette date là mais je pense
qu'il y aura des hommes parce
qu'aujourd'hui il ya un manque à gagner
énorme on parle de 35 milliards d'euros
de pertes pour l'instant dans le monde
du voyage dans les compagnies air ils
savent assez monté jusqu'à la fin
d'année jusqu'à 280 milliards
bernat est ce qu'il ya des compagnies
aériennes qui vont pouvoir s'en remettre
où il ya des compagnies aériennes qui
vont faire faillite à votre ami moi j'ai
peur je vous le dis sincèrement syrie
que des compagnies aériennes qui sont
les postes disparaissent l'accord de
cette situation et le problème c'est que
l'argent que vous aurez payé vous en
tant que voyageur vous trouverez pas il
ya aucune caisse de garantie
quand vous achetez un forfait à biot et
le social cyril vous savez très bien
vous avez une garantie financière avec
la sueur ps et qu est la garantie
financière
mais si vous achetez sage directement
auprès d'une compagnie si elle disparaît
vous perdez tout c'est incroyable et est
ce qu'on pensait qu'à des grosses ou des
gros clubs de vacances aussi qu'ils vont
faire faillite
est ce que le peut mais tu vas tenir ou
pas par exemple voir le club med n'a pas
touché d'argent sont plus gros
d'actionnaires est un actionnaire
chinois et je suis sûr dans tous les cas
que le club méditerranée a un réservoir
finances et qui lui permettra de tenir
ne soyez pas inquiet pour des marques
comme ça j'en suis engagé pour des
petites marques et les petites marques
qui vont les clubs marmara tout ça voilà
c'est ça qu'est ce qu'ils vont devenir
alors c'est un grand groupe ada marra je
vois bien sûr qu'ils s'appellent
solide du moins je l'espère on a vu
aussi que touba ce conflit a disparu
alors personnes s'y attendait j'espère
que tu es 8 sera aidé évidemment pas
reparlé ses actionnaires principaux pour
tenir le mais alors juste bernard est ce
que il ya des hôtels qui vont
disparaître ici parce qu'il ya plein
d'hôtels des petits hôtels aussi il ya
plein de gens qui ont des petits hôtels
sur la côte d'azur en bretagne en
normandie
qu'est ce qui va se passer de ces petits
hôtels qui sont pas adossées à des
grands groupes
est-ce qu'ils vont peuvent mettre la clé
sous la porte bon je pense que dans tous
les cas je vous rappelle quand même
puisque alliés le gouvernement j'espère
qu'ils tiendront leurs engagements et
aujourd'hui dans tous les cas isolé des
villes isolées aider les pme ça veut
dire donc les petits hôtels et petites
structures
regardez sébastien bazin il disait sur
votre antenne denner donc seul sans news
c'est le patron d'accor c'est assez
nouveau bac aurait ôté la classe et lui
disait la chose suivante on a trois cent
mille personnes en termes d'effectifs on
a mis deux cent vingt mille au chômage
il ya 90 personnes
on est obligé d'accompagner on va aider
les hôtels on va les financer on va les
accompagner et on va les réouvrir on va
peut-être aussi le mettre à disposition
de du monde hospitalier à 30 euros par
jour donc il ya des solutions d'attentes
pour aider pour accompagner ses petits
seins
ces petites infrastructures hôtelières
alors plusieurs ministres déconseillé
aux français de réserver leurs vacances
et vous non voyance par jay vacances que
c'est un sujet qui vous concerne le legs
bernard sabbah donc consultant voyages
spécialiste voyage est ce que il faut
avoir peur d'une deuxième vague bernard
puisque il ya plein de mini ce qu'ils
ont dit il faut pas partir à l'étranger
vous conseillez pas partir à l'étranger
même si même si c'est autorisé moi je
dit pour l'instant que il faut voyager
en europe
il faut voyager en france maintenant
pour le reste je n'ai aucune garantie
si vous partez en corée du sud
aujourd'hui ils sont bien en avance ils
peuvent maîtrise parfaitement tous ses
problèmes médicaux
surtout on avance israël a fermé ses
frontières depuis le 1er mars
donc israël je te pend sera réouvert
pour une partie de la population
donc ce qui permettra d'aider le maroc
indique le cross le maroc gère très bien
le maroc gère très bien aussi un signal
et le maroc la tunisie gère très bien
cette crise la race et 50 usd ou la
garantie syrie il faudra des visas si
sanitaires
il faudra des caméras thermiques dans
les aéroports il faut qu'on prenne la
température des gens et qu'on sache où
on va c'est compliqué aujourd'hui alors
juste votre conseil bernard sabbah parce
que y'a plein de gens aussi qu'ils
disent
prix vont flamber forcément en france
parce que tout le monde va rester en
france
est ce que les prix ne vont pas flambé
dans les hôtels dans les clubs de
vacances dans l'est dans les restaurants
et crs que les prix vont flamber ou pas
parce que c'est une inquiétude des
téléspectateurs ça je le dis franchement
si les prix flambent c'est une erreur et
c'est une politique à court terme de
tous les acteurs il faut conserver les
mêmes prix soyez fait des promotions en
dehors de mois de juillet août
mais pour mais ne laissez pas de
rattraper en multipliant par deux ou par
trois le voyage certain vent l'acheter
vous allez le regretter moi je le dis
aux acteurs du tourisme
soyez vigilants penser à la durée on
sait sur la continuité si les facteurs
du voyage si vous êtes agent de voyages
s'il est relié jouets jeux et des
justement les gens à changer
d'environnement avec tout ce qu'ils ont
vécu du compliment ils vont vouloir
partir encourager les mais jean-michel
oui évidemment c'est merveilleux la
grèce le maroc la tunisie et cetera mais
cette année c'est un excellent
restaurant france que son travail et les
restaurateurs les soldats ni pas bien
sûr et les hôtels et jean michel mathieu
parent dont bernard moi j'encourage
personnes appartiennent effectivement
pour plusieurs raisons la première vous
l'avez dit j'ai des amis qui en ce
moment en galère pour se faire
rembourser
quand sergei compagnies aériennes alors
dit non mais c'était par le site que par
lequel vous avez machin du cancer
cityville c'est la compagnie ils sont
pas remboursés je rappelle aussi que si
par hasard une deuxième bague et comparé
ne serait ce qu'au mois d'août en grèce
et qu'on est confiné qu'on doit rester à
l'extérieur comme ça et là plein de gens
que ses pattes au maroc on est planté
l'extérieur je rappelle aussi qu'au note
toujours toujours toujours pas de preuve
que dans un avion on ne reste plus rien
pour l'instant tout le monde du tout et
son contraire
oh pardon mais pour l'instant
effectivement réservé des vacances ce
serait vraiment vraiment à mon sens par
dont bernard à se pressent contre votre
paroisse n'a pour l'instant ce jeu c'est
vraiment pour moi n'a pas vraiment pas
la chose à faire
d'accord mais germain consultant je le
pressens que je ne vends dans je vous le
dis je ne prêche pour aucune paroisse je
dis juste
dernièrement je pense qu'il est
important de ne pas décourager les gens
de partir mais en même temps d'être
vigilant sur le plan sanitaire
donc ça c'est non c'est ça que j'ai dit